jörg brase ist unser türkei
korrespondent guten morgen um was geht
es der türkei in diesem punkt
als ich den widerspruch gehört habe
dachte ich mir dass es um zwei sachen
geht zum einen um politische zeichen
richtung moskau zu senden und natürlich
auch richtung nato was moskau angeht die
türkei unterhält engste beziehungen zu
präsident putin natürlich weil russland
zu den großen energielieferanten gehört
und die türkei auf russisches erdgas
angewiesen ist man bringt sich auch
immer wieder als vermittler ins spiel
zwischen russland und der ukraine
und so war es wahrscheinlich ankara
wichtig zu zeigen dass man nicht alles
mitmachen will was der westen vor hat
und dann ging es eben um ein zeichen an
die nato es gibt ja immer wieder streit
zwischen der zweit größten militärmacht
nach den usa der türkei und den anderen
nato mitgliedern die türkei ist der
meinung dass die nato dass der westen
die eigenen sicherheitsinteressen zum
beispiel in nordsyrien nicht ausreichend
berücksichtigt und dann geht es vor
allem um den machtkampf mit griechenland
im mittelmeer da ist man der meinung
dass die nato dass die eu sich einseitig
auf die seite griechenlands schlägt und
dann geht es um rüstungsgeschäfte mit
russland die türkei hatte er das
luftabwehrsystem s400 gekauft das hatte
zu großem streit geführt daraufhin
hatten die usa die türkei aus dem
gemeinsamen
entwicklungsprojekt des f-35 bombers
rausgeworfen und jetzt vermuten einige
dass es der türkei darum gehen könnte
für eine zustimmung zur mitgliedschaft
von finnland und schweden wieder in
dieses programm reinzukommen am mittwoch
will der türkische aussenminister sich
in washington mit den usa treffen und da
muss man dann sehen was da auf den tisch
kommt wie sehr nutzten erdogan jetzt dem
türkischen präsidenten die haltung die
er gegenüber der nato vertritt im
eigenen land
also man kann natürlich davon ausgehen
dass die islamisch konservative
wählerklientel das gut heißt was der
präsident erdogan da tut denn die mhp
die nationalistische partei ist
bündnispartner und dort wird es sehr
positiv aufgenommen dass der präsident
sich gegen diesen plan der nato stellt
im nächsten jahr sind
präsidentschaftswahlen unterliegt
natürlich die vermutung nahe dass
erdogan da die konservative klientel
mobilisieren will dass er da stimmen
einsammeln will denn wirtschaftlich ist
die lage extrem schlecht die inflation
ist auf rekordhoch und da kann man
denken das ist da ganz gut in den plan
passt dass man die aufmerksamkeit von
der wirtschaft jetzt ein bisschen wieder
auf ausländische auf aussenpolitische
themen lenken kann einschätzungen von
unseren türkei korrespondent jörg brase
live vielen dank
unser top thema heute finnland und
schweden wollen in die nato doch die
türkei stellt sich quer und wie reagiert
putin auf die nord erweiterung des top
thema jetzt im zdf morgenmagazin
ja man muss auch noch mal sagen seit dem
apollinischen kriegen war schweben nicht
mehr teil eines militärischen bündnisses
für über 70 jahre hatte sich finnland
der neutralität verschrieben und jetzt
sehen beide länder ihr heil in einer
mitgliedschaft bei der problem ist nur
damit es wirklich passiert müssen alle
30 nato staaten zustimmen und das wird
gar nicht so einfach darüber rede ich
gleich mit einer frau die die nato
wirklich in und auswendig kennt sie hat
22 jahre für das verteidigungsbündnis
gearbeitet zuvor florian hahn
es ist nur eine außenministerin die
gleich ein blatt papier unterzeichnet
ein außenminister der das anderswo eben
so tut und es ist doch so viel mehr
es ist ein bedeutsamer ein sehr ernster
moment und es fühlt sich an als ob wir
das tun von dem wir denken dass es das
beste für schweden ist
schweden und finnland zwei länder die
sich jahrhundertelang auf ihre eigenen
armeen verließen suchen den schutz der
nato sie sollen ihnen schnell bekommen
meint nicht nur der deutsche kanzler
deutschland wird sich dafür einsetzen
dass das beitrittsverfahren sehr zügig
vonstatten geht die ratifikation durch
die bundesrepublik deutschland werden
wir in abstimmung mit den
verfassungsorganen unverzüglich
durchführen wir laden andere staaten ein
das gleiche zu tun andere wie die türkei
das land ist seit 1952 nato mitglied der
präsident entdeckt nicht zum ersten mal
seine vetomacht recep tayyip erdogan
wirft schweden und finnland vor sie
unterstützten die als terrororganisation
eingestufte kurdische pkk
wie können wir ihnen trauen schweden ist
eine brutstätte für terrororganisationen
viele basis funktionieren in der türkei
und manchmal ist die mentalität vor
allem von logan ja auch sehr davon
geprägt es geht glaube ich riskiere es
zusagen nicht um die kurdenfrage in
schweden und finnland es geht um etwas
anders womöglich um diese us-kampfjets
die die usa seit 2009 10 nicht mehr an
die türkei liefern weil erdogan
regierung damals ein russisches
raketenabwehrsystem kaufte unklar ob
erdogan sich die lieferung nun erpresst
oder ob er die gerade geeinte nato mit
einem veto ins mark trifft es würde
tatsächlich putin in die hände spielen
das würde das zeichen geben es gibt
keine einheit auf seiten der nato von
daher wäre das genau das falsche signal
zur falschen zeitpunkt es ist eine
historische zeitenwende für die nato und
den norden europas noch aber hängt sie
an einem seidenen faden aus der türkei
und darüber möchte ich jetzt mit einer
frau sprechen die 22 jahre für das
verteidigungsbündnis gearbeitet hat sie
war viele jahre chefin des nato
planungsstabs und
höchstrangige deutsche frau im
internationalen starb der nato
mittlerweile ist sie politikberaterin
schirm morgen nach kiel stefanie babst
guten morgen wir haben gerade die sagen
wir mal schwierige situationen rund um
die türkei gesehen glauben sie am ende
macht präsident erdogan mit wenn man ihm
einfach gibt babbel
davon gehe ich aus aber vor uns liegen
wahrscheinlich noch einige tage und
wochen der diplomatischen verhandlungen
des rings denn unsere türkischen
verbündeten werden nicht so einfach
nachgeben aber am ende denke ich wenn
sie das tun 1995 sind finnland und
schweden der eu beigetreten jetzt wollen
beide zeitgleich in die nato damit wird
ja die finnisch russische grenze zur
nato grenze was bringen die beitritte
ihrer meinung nach
also diese beiden staaten sind ja sehr
solide und berechenbare eu-mitglieder
sie sind ganz hervorragende nato-partner
in den letzten jahren gewesen sie sind
demokratische stabile länder und sie
haben wirklich erstklassige militärische
streitkräfte und vor diesem hintergrund
denke ich bringen beide finnland und
schweden eine ganze menge mit an den
tisch und werden das bündnis sicherlich
in vielerlei hinsicht auch neu beleben
aber darüber hinaus werden natürlich die
beitrittsverhandlungen jetzt erstmal
ergeben was genau in zukunft der beitrag
der beiden staaten zur nato sein wird
und was genau oder wie genau dass putin
findet weiß man gerade auch nicht die
nato erweiterung sei keine unmittelbare
bedrohung sagt er sollte aber die nato
militärische infrastruktur an die grenze
verlegen dann werde es eine reaktion
geben was könnte das sein das ist ein
typischer putin spruch wenn ich das mal
so sagen darf also er behält sich quasi
offen was genau eine russische reaktion
dann sein wird er hat einen relativ
großen instrumentenkasten der reicht von
cyber angriffen des stabilisierungs
informationskampagnen bis hin zur
stationierung von taktischen
nuklearwaffen auf der gegen küste also
in kaliningrad stehen ja ist kann der
raketen mittelstreckenraketen und die
könnte er beispielsweise auch nuclear
bestücken oder solche raketen
stärker oder vielmehr enger an die
finnische grenze
verlegen aber all das ist noch offen und
er behält sich das vor und wird denn die
militärische infrastruktur und die
grenze verlegt ich meine sie kennen ja
die nato in und auswendig
wir werden ja nun erst einmal die
beitrittsverhandlungen abwarten und ich
gehe davon aus dass fragen der
nato-truppen stationierung da eine ganz
entscheidende rolle spielen werden die
schweden haben ja bereits gesagt sie
wollen erst einmal keine militärische
infrastrukturen schon gar keine klare
struktur auf ihrem land aber all das ist
noch sehr früh dass gegenwärtig zu
beurteilen weil dass es gegenstand der
verhandlung sein sondern pop ups bei uns
werden ja gerade zwei lesarten
diskutiert die eine die ukraine mit
allem unterstützen was sie braucht und
die andere bloß nicht weiter eskalieren
putin könnte salopp gesagt auf den knopf
drücken sehen sie diese gefahr
ernsthafter
also ich sehe vor allen dingen das
putting mit unserer angst spielt der
westlichen angst vor eskalation das ist
eine angst die ist schon länger gibt
aber sie ist berechenbar also die
politik präsident putins ist berechenbar
in dieser form und ich denke es wird
wirklich darum gehen
russland einst zu dem wirklich
geschlossen unseren ganzen
instrumentenkasten zu nutzen um
russlands aktionsradius in zukunft zu
beschränken also eine rolle beckers
strategie mit auf den weg zu bringen ist
aus meiner sicht wirklich jetzt das was
ansteht und sich weniger von angst
leiten zu lassen das klingt erst mal
beruhigend was sie da sagen von außen
hat man den eindruck dass man überhaupt
nicht einschätzen kann was er eigentlich
macht oder will es gibt ja bei diesen
alten satz wer zuerst drückt stirbt als
zweiter das kann ja eigentlich niemand
wollen welche zugeständnisse könnte die
nato den russland gegenüber machen oder
sagen sie überhaupt keine sondern jetzt
richtig harter hand
also die frage wie sich der westen in
zukunft gegenüber russland ausstellen
will wird ja gerade erst diskutiert wir
sind dann noch sehr am anfang einer
wirklich schwierigen politischen
diskussion und man sieht die
unterschiedlichen nuancen zwischen den
verbündeten
die einen reden von einer
gesichtswahrenden lösung die man putin
anbieten müsste die anderen reden von
einem waffenstillstand dem man schnell
erreichen müsste und andere wie
beispielsweise die balten und polen
bezeichnen präsident putin als einen
kriegsverbrecher demgegenüber man
eigentlich keine kompromisse eingehen
lassen müsste also all das wird in
zukunft eine schwierige debatte sein ich
persönlich bin der meinung dass vor
allen dingen der aktionsradius russlands
also seine möglichkeiten zur
stabilisierung
eingegrenzt werden müssen mit allen
instrumenten die wir haben welche fehler
das klingt ja so ein bisschen so dass
man vorher zu weich gegenüber russland
war welche fehler hat denn der westen
oder die nato da gemacht ihrer meinung
nach
wir haben denke ich über eine lange zeit
gesehen dass präsident putin
internationales recht bricht dass er
durchaus bereit ist militärische gewalt
anzuwenden ich denke da an georgien
südossetien oder natürlich auch die
illegale alexander grimm und haben nicht
wirklich nachhaltig darauf reagiert und
unsere eigene politik russland gegenüber
auch an bedingungen geknüpft das war ein
fehler und das dürfen wir in zukunft
nicht noch einmal wiederholen sagt
stefanie babst 22 jahre für das
verteidigungsbündnis also für die nato
gearbeitet hat vielen herzlichen dank
für das gespräch und ihre einschätzung
gerne